all right look man bullet cat podcast we
got my guy gripping the [ __ ]
building man his new album is out right
now go support it uh go support all his
out go listen just go dive in on the
dsps on this guy shady records
latest signee
hit that [ __ ] man let's
let him know why eminem's [ __ ] with
you grip let's get it
yeah
can you hear me a little bit on the
phone yeah
though
i suggest
i stay in my bed like a [ __ ] with a
broke [ __ ] slow sipper less chaser mo
liquor flow sicker gross figures while
they post pictures flow the holy ghost
allow me to quote scriptures riddle me
this who is illinois you couldn't walk
in my shoes here give it a try you silly
insinuating you got a ceiling this high
where i'm from to make a living you got
to be willing to die the villain is guy
junkie functional alcoholic shaky by the
ankles see you come up off your wallet
you fell off so you made excuses and
your fans bought it but if you ain't
finished [ __ ] get the [ __ ] up off the
toilet if not i'm on my way to drop a
turd in your yard and broad day then
take a saw blade to your burglar bars
grabbing you dragging you through the
crib headed to the door got you clawing
to your fingernails embedded in the
floor you don't understand my hunger you
ain't never been this poor i went from
being heavily ignored to scheduling the
tour it was a rough grind through tough
times dark dark and battered heart was
shattered now i'm on tracks with
marshall mathers beast mode used to
sneak mama's cheap old van couldn't
sleep though on the lookout for the repo
man i keep the heat hope but it beat
your ass if we throwing hats he won a
verse he came with seven i need three
more bands [ __ ] had one hot summer so
they spun them a sequel [ __ ] flop they
on top until they plummet beneath you
[ __ ] fumbled it now he's stumbling in
my dm's like bro what's a good number to
reach you the function make you vomit
[ __ ] stomach is people don't get eight
i'm number eight when he was running
with diesel it should have free throwing
seas no i ain't one of your equals write
it with four guns and a regal none of
them legal
a lot of [ __ ] boast a lot of [ __ ]
brag these raps will probably be your
body with attack [ __ ] i been a problem
[ __ ] i'm jotting in the pack and i'm
checking for me like fries at the bottom
of the bag quit the fiction telling we
don't buy the [ __ ] you're selling i kick
it with convicted felons that i split
your melon you made the coffin now i
just gotta stick the nailing
international sex symbol i got [ __ ]
yelling grip that's bae tripping strap
spray listen little man i don't care
what your raps say i'm wicked at slavery
spit at your lady with a mercedes white
with cream interior biscuit and gravy
tunnel vision is crazy none of the
dishes are phased me em said i was next
y'all better listen to shady they sign
him oh my god why how come quit asking
questions [ __ ] go listen to the album
go listen to the album
like number eight when he was running
with diesel i died for this
yo now go get it